and then you feel it I can always feel
there'll be like a hush behind me you
know what I mean people will be talking
and you feel this hush and you know that
they're saying something about you and
especially now you know people can get
on their phones and they'll be like hey
Chad
your name's Chad right and I'll be like
yeah you got your phone right
I know this is like a weird like creepy
question but are you a people watcher
and I don't mean it in like so many
people but it's also studying human
nature and observing people is what a
minute yeah yeah I am an observer I'm
the guy who will be on the wall at a
party just kind of watching I'm not the
guy who's like you know I am I watch
people and now you know it's tricky when
they watch you so it's kind of an
interesting dichotomy is that right
that's right weird dichotomy use it go
for it really yes what its own it's
interesting when you you you know when
once fame sort of enters the food that
the picture you know and then you have
people staring at you and so it makes it
interesting right for the times that
meaning you feel and you can blend in
more which probably's is not often but
like let's suppose you have a hat on or
you just feel like maybe you're in a
space where no one's really - celebrity
focused it's maybe another town or
something what what catches your eye
about people in terms of character study
like is there you know because for me
I'll see people at the grocery store and
it'll be the person that's not really
that glamorous but they're just doing
their own thing and I'm like zeroed in
on that totally it's the people that
have like interesting tics or walks or
that have a disability you know I'm
fascinated by how they operate with life
in how they're interacting with people
so I'll really zero in on on that
because it's something I don't know but
yeah you know people do catch my eye and
then I'll try not to stare because his
room is there sure but I want to know
you know and a lot of those things I
have brought in in different characters
you know I'll see somebody doing it
from years ago you're like okay that
might work for this so observing is key
I think to acting you know yeah and on
the flip side when the eyes are on you
and maybe you're in more of a public
setting how does that feel do you ever
feel pressure to be superhuman in some
ways yeah I mean you have to be well it
depends on where it's at if you're at an
event you know where people are there to
see you yes you know you're on and it's
a your present and and it's a beautiful
thing and then sometimes you know I will
have my hat on somewhere and I'm
completely not even thinking about it
and then somebody will recognize you or
and it just catches you off-guard you
know and you're like okay wait yeah I am
in the public eye I have to remind
myself you know because I'll forget
especially like it here in LA where was
this kind of our safe zone as actors in
a way but still I'll be at the Ralph's
you know we're happy not and Ralph is a
local grocery Mart in LA is we love him
here but I'll be there now thinking of
it and then somebody will say hey or you
know like oh wait you're right because
when you go out of La that's when people
get really really excited
you know because they don't see
celebrities all the time you know it's
not in LA we see everybody you know and
we sort of like okay and this is where
they live and we respect that but when
you go outside of LA that's when that's
when people get really pumped not to say
that they don't hear but it's just a
different thing right
just because today we're in this new age
of phones and you know people get in
fights on subways instead of calling 911
they just take their phone out do you
feel any pressure that even if you're
just you know at Ralph's and you're you
know looking at the rock stars or that
you know whatever energy drinks or
something and then you feel someone's
presence do you feel a little more
self-conscious absolutely absolutely
does make you feel self-conscious when
someone's sitting there kind of and I
always feel it I can whenever I go into
someplace now
of being recognizable I will sort of
case the place before now ah going
somewhere you know kind of be like okay
this person will probably recognize me
and then you feel it I can always feel
there'll be like a hush behind me you
know what I mean people will be talking
and you feel this hush and you know that
they're saying something about you and
especially now you know people can get
on their phones and they'll be like hey
Chad
your name's Chad right and I'll be like
yeah you got your phone right back in a
day you know it was like hey Jesse hey
ash and I still get that a lot but now
the phones people can just go and type
your name right away and figure out who
you are on the flip side I think these
are weapons too I think we do have to be
careful in these times because I've had
plenty of people just all of a sudden
just do it just do this to me and I'm
like do you want a photo yeah yeah yeah
well how about you get in it and how
about I take the photo and we can both
be in it
Fame is an interesting thing to watch
people's how they react to it it's
almost like some people can show and be
cool some people whose their bodily
functions it's it's fascinating to watch
yeah and and then some people will have
a conversation about you and we'll be
just as close as we are and they'll be
talking as if you don't exist like
you're an object it's fascinating it's
fascinating and I'd really try I don't
take it personally
you know in a minute I understand that's
the inner workings of Fame and how it
works and in celebrity but a lot of
times it can be invasive sometimes you
know when people you know follow you
into a restroom or you know these things
happen yeah but ninety-eight percent of
time it's love and it's I feel really
really fortunate to have been in in
projects that people know and they
recognize me and and that's you know
people are recognizing your work and
that's
that's a great thing I know I've heard
Marc Maron talk about he could feel the
room when he would go up on stage and
tell what was going to be sort of a
crowd that he would play to and they
would love and then vice versa and I
think I heard nikki sixx say the same
thing he was very sensitive to the
energy around him so when you feel that
maybe the energy isn't totally friendly
what do you do do you leave I leave okay
I leave I've been in plenty of
situations where people have wanted to
fight me because I'm famous because
maybe there were people in the room or a
female hope that got excited and wanted
a photo and I've had several people over
the years want to come out and hurt me
and I just very coolly be like it's not
it's not me that you're upset with here
it's whatever you got going on and it
and and it's cool and then I'll leave
I'll never stick around if somebody
wants to challenge me because you know
hey Hollywood you know I don't I don't
put up with it so but you know it
happens it's see I always say if Fame is
a double-edged sword right and I just
have one last question then we'll move
on sure I feel like I'm grilling you
guys all right
when when you felt that that changed in
your life because I'm sure there were
times when in the beginning you could go
places and then maybe people didn't have
their agendas whether it was they were
in love with you or they were jealous of
you whatever it was but when you felt it
shift how was that for you I remember
the moment that shifted and that was the
day after fast nefarious came out we my
family and I had gone to see it like in
a town near Seattle and we wind it off
here we watched it and then we came out
and I got mauled by people it was insane
and I was like whoa you know because I
didn't expect that movie you know my mom
asked me to she wanted to have a film
premiere of The Fast and the Furious
back home and I said I go mom no one's
ever gonna see this film because I was
ignorant I was very young and I didn't
understand again
you know we go back to being young and
sort of having those big hits you know
you don't realize what you have and that
movie taught me that you never never
know and I was so lucky to be a part of
this huge phenomenon and to this day
people recognize Jessie left and right
so I'm really fortunate and I and then
after I got mold I went to another place
and got mold again and then it just kept
happening and I remember that night just
like it freaked me out so much and I was
kind of like I you know it was crying I
was like I was really upset and my mom
was there I'm like this things have
changed things have definitely changed
and it was a tearful joy but also scary
because it's like whoa
you feel the shift and then it hasn't
been the same sense and so you kind of
learn to adjust and you know and again
I'm very thankful for it is a
interesting position to be in
yeah I think a lot of people don't think
about that because we're in such an era
of people wanting to be famous whether
it's on tumblr Instagram Twitter
whatever but then there is a stubble
edges or but then you know the Chad that
was the little boy in the second grade
and you know a different Chad and the
way maybe the world projects so it's got
to be an interesting thing because you
know yourself as Chad the human and
other people see as an actor superhuman
you know right they do a lot of people
see their perception mmm what they want
to think of you it doesn't it's not who
I am it's just what they see and what
they want to sort of put into into their
little box about who you are and we do
that with you think a lot of celebrities
we just truly don't know you know my
favorite is when somebody says Oh
so-and-so's an a-hole I go really have
you ever met this person and we're
talking about a celebrity oh this
celebrity is in an a-hole really have
you ever met them no and I'm like even
you can never say that about this person
you can't because somebody outside out
there saying that Chad Lindbergh's an
a-hole because I looked in a certain way
or I didn't hear them and my Anejo know
so it's interesting when people say
that I just I just think you know unless
you know somebody in this business you
don't know them so sure well I know
Mickey Rourke was interviewed and he
said that LA was a town built on envy
and I think that is true
in many ways and and so I think
sometimes a lot of it comes from that
sure anyway thank you yeah thank you and
I love hearing those story I mean from
guys that have been around doing this
for years you know I've been doing this
a long time but he's been doing a long
time and it's interesting to hear
similar stories I yeah it was a Piers
Morgan interview those the Mickey Rourke
was excellent Wow okay cool cool so
we'll move on from awesome
you